well first and foremost I'm a filmmaker
I don't know whether I've ever formally
trained in history I mean the last time
I took a course in American history was
11th grade when they hold a gun to your
head and and and make you take it I've
always wanted to be a filmmaker for
almost as long as I can remember my
mother died of cancer when I was 11
there wasn't a moment when I wasn't
aware that she was dying after she died
my father had a very strict curfew for
me and my younger brother would forgive
it if there was a movie late at night on
TV there even on a school night that
might go to 2am and I remember watching
my father cry a couple years after my
mother died he hadn't died at her
funeral I've gotten cried at her funeral
and I realized how much power there was
in this world of filmmaking and I became
convinced that I was going to be the
next John Ford or Alfred Hitchcock or
Howard Hawks those are old American
movie directors and I went to college
assuming that be the case but all of my
teachers in Hampshire College in amherst
massachusetts in the fall of 1971 were
social documentary still photographers
who reminded me i think quite correctly
there's much more drama in what is and
what was than anything the human
imagination makes up and it's only later
that I realized that what I wanted to do
is about American history but it's
completely I'm completely untrained and
untutored
well I you know I remember being
obviously very impressed with the
nascent cinema verite movement there was
so much energy in it and that would be
John Marshall on Frederick Wiseman I
guess would be the chief purveyors
rickielee the ancient tradition of
documentary goes back to clarity and one
always absorbs his thing I particularly
like a British director named John
grierson whose night mail is one of my
favorite films are kind of more composed
and formalistic documentary for the BBC
Perry Miller a dot o made a film in the
early 70s about Gertrude Stein call when
this you see remember me that used
actors to read on camera the the words
of the people the characters in this
biography of Gertrude Stein and I was
really fascinated and in some way my
pioneering use of first-person voices to
complement a third-person narrator was
born in the inspiration I found in her
very completely different work but
nonetheless very seminal and influential
to me but you know Orson Welles the
French New Wave antonioni I think
particularly my two favorite directors
or three favorite directors if I had to
do that would be coração Boone well and
Buster Keaton and not necessarily in
that order